this morning in our saturday session
jeff tweedy like many of us a celebrated
front man for the band wilco
has spent much of the year hanging
around his house but quarantine hasn't
slowed down tweety's prolific writing
in fact this month he released a book
and just yesterday a new solo album
and that's not all we're going to hear
from jeff tweedy in a performance in
just a moment but first anthony mason
spoke with him
about his busy year
hey wake up
[Music]
even in a pandemic jeff tweedy and his
family
have been prolific
[Music]
you've been doing sessions at home
during the pandemic
but almost every day yeah
on my wife's instagram
[Music]
it's become a thing all right you want
your song was that something you
you needed to do the initial impulse was
to cheer my wife up
i think she was disappointed that i was
home
from tour
wilco's summer tour was cancelled and
tweety has no idea
when he'll perform in front of a live
audience again
just started playing songs occasionally
we did it every night we've done like
107
shows
[Music]
i just felt a need to have some routine
some
some daily connection to my family
and to share some sense of reliability
and normalcy
and then you and then you went and
recorded an album as well
you know i was just given all of this
time that i wouldn't have otherwise had
his work for the new album love is the
king wasn't the only writing tweedy did
in june soon after the death of george
floyd
tweedy put out this statement on twitter
pledging
five percent of his songwriting
royalties to groups working for racial
justice
and challenged the industry to follow
him
the modern music industry he wrote is
built almost entirely
on black art everybody in my profession
i truly believe
if i have any kind of connection to rock
and roll any kind of connection to
popular music of the last hundred years
you owe a debt to somebody that wasn't
paid
and um primarily people that were of
african-american descent there's there's
respect paid but not necessarily money
it's it's still
it's still an uneven playing field and i
don't think a lot of people
want to believe that maybe but it but it
is
in the seven months since the pandemic
began tweety has also written
and published a new book i was struck by
the title
which is how to write one song
not how to write songs right if you want
to write two songs you have to buy two
books
it's not just a guidebook for
songwriters it's a meditation on
tweedy's own
creative process what does creativity
do for you it's a good way to kill
time without hurting anybody you know i
think it's
it's better for me than other things
that i've done in my life to kill time
it teaches me about myself it functions
the same way i think meditation might
function for a lot of people
you've been incredibly productive
mentally how do you feel you weathered
the pandemic i have struggled with uh
with depression and and anxiety disorder
for
for almost my entire life so
i feel like i feel pre-pandemic
i actually feel well suited
in fact it's a little easier
there's something about having to to
cope with those particular types of
mental health issues that has
prepared us for a quarantine